Veterisidial is the drug that my ecologist may recommend for me. Please see the
screenshots. Yes, I did. I saw the email of that. What do you think about that
with dim to regulate my hormones instead of tamoxin if it is very easy or okay
or not good? Well, remember the law. I can't comment on drugs. So if it's a
prescription medication, that's something you have to talk to your
prescribed doctor about. That's where I have to draw the line with our just with
our medical legal perspective that we cannot be saying, oh, yeah, that's a good
drug. You should take that drug or don't ever take that drug and then you know
that gets back and that's just I can't legally do that. So I'm not a prescribed
doctor. So you have to talk to a prescribed doctor about that. With any drug, we
always recommend that you Google it and you Google inside effects of it and
you Google any studies you can find about it. So but I apologize. I just have
to stay medical legal all that.